-Everybody, welcome to the show.
Thank you for watching.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
They are the Roots right there.
Thank you for tuning in.
It's been a pretty crazy day
with the storm
hitting the East Coast.
Extreme winds and thousands
of power outages,
so everyone out there,
stay safe.
And we're thinking
about you guys.
Alright. Let's get to some news
and jokes.
Well, guys, everybody
is talking about this.
Last night HBO aired
Jonathan Swan's interview
with President Trump,
and let's just say
it was so bad
it made his coronavirus
briefings look good.
The interview was such
a disaster, at one point FEMA
showed up and wrapped Trump
in a foil blanket.
[ Laughter ]
You could tell things
weren't going well
because midway through Trump
asked
if he could talk
to Chris Wallace instead.
-Incidentally, I took the test,
too,
when I heard that you passed it.
-Yeah, how did you do?
-It's not the hardest test.
-No.
-The picture --
-The last --
-It's an elephant.
-"Well, elephant, doesn't really
look like an elephant."
If you don't know
Jonathan Swan,
he's an Australian reporter,
which is fun
because we got to see
a Trump interview
go down the drain
in the opposite direction.
[ Laughter ]
Trump did so poorly,
the only HBO interview
he'll do now is
Elmo's late-night talk show.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The interview was on HBO,
which is why beforehand
they showed this graphic.
Adult content, child language,
brief stupidity.
[ Laughter ]
The interview started off
with Swan asking Trump
about his response
to the coronavirus.
Let's see how that went.
-When they hear you say
everything's under control,
don't worry about wearing masks,
it's giving them
a false sense of security.
-Right now,
I think it's under control.
-How?
A thousand Americans
are dying a day.
-They're dying, that's true.
It is what it is.
-"It is what it is"?
You're the President
of the United States.
You're not Paulie Walnuts
delivering bad news
to Tony Soprano.
"Sorry, T, things got
a little messy.
It is what it is, capisce?"
[ Laughter ]
At funerals while everyone says,
"my condolences,"
Trump's like,
"It is what it is."
[ Laughter ]
"Where are the refreshments?"
That reminds me of the moment
after the attack
on Pearl Harbor when FDR said,
"Eh, what are you going to do?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, move over, MAGA.
We got a new hat on the market.
There it is.
"It is what it is."
From there things escalated
when Swan directly confronted
Trump on the country's
COVID statistics
and Trump responded by
pulling out a bunch of charts.
Watch this.
-United States is lowest
in numerous categories.
We're lower than the world.
-Lower than the world?
-We're lower than --
-In what? In what?
-Take a look.
Right here.
Look.
Here is the United States.
You have to go by the cases.
You take the number of cases.
Look, we're last.
Meaning we're first.
Take a look.
Again, it's cases.
-Trump looks like every dad
looking at IKEA instructions.
This one -- hold on,
this was the -- wait.
You put the flugendorf
in the flugen.
No. I'm holding the flugen.
How can I put it in the --
Eventually Trump just tossed
500 pages into the air,
and when they landed,
he was gone.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see one
of Trump's charts again?
Swan was like, "Sir, that's just
the alignment page
from your printer."
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So his response to
the coronavirus questions
wasn't Trump's finest moment.
Let's see if he can bounce back.
Here's Swan asking about
civil rights icon John Lewis.
-How do you think history
will remember John Lewis?
-I don't know.
I really don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know John Lewis.
He chose not to come
to my inauguration.
-He can hold a grudge, huh?
You know Trump's probably
keeping stimulus checks
from all the kids
who didn't show up
to his 5th birthday party.
Trump's upset John Lewis
didn't come to his inauguration.
He was like,
"I hope he'd be there.
I even held 2 million seats
open for him."
[ Laughter ]
If all that wasn't bad enough,
for the second time
in two weeks,
Trump was asked for his thoughts
on Jeffrey Epstein's
former associate,
Ghislaine Maxwell,
and once again he said this.
-She's now in jail.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, I wish her well.
I'd wish you well.
I'd wish a lot of people well.
Good luck.
Let them prove
somebody was guilty.
Her boyfriend died in jail,
and people are trying to figure
out how did it happen?
Was it suicide? Was he killed?
And I do wish her well.
I'm not looking
for anything bad for her.
-Man, for a guy who owned
a bunch of casinos,
you think he'd know
when to stop doubling down.
Stop wishing her well.
She's an accused sex trafficker,
not a kid going off to college
for the first time.
He's so nice to
Ghislaine Maxwell,
which can only mean
she went to his inauguration.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, a lot of people
are calling
Trump's interview a train wreck.
And get this. Apparently HBO had
to delete some of
the best moments for time.
But we managed to get our hands
on the footage.
Check this out.
♪♪
-How do you think history
will remember John Lewis?
-John Lewis, look, he didn't
come to my inauguration.
So I'm not a fan.
The Dalai Lama didn't
come either.
Neither did Mother Teresa.
She's very mean.
Very nasty to me.
She was.
I don't anything
about John Lewis.
For me, it goes, person, woman,
man, camera, TV,
and then way down the list
maybe John Lewis.
We'll see.
-The criticism of you
that is most prominent
is about the communication.
It's the public health experts
saying that it needs
to be based in reality.
-Look, it is based on reality.
What people don't realize
is America might have
a lot of Americans with COVID,
but we have very few
British people with COVID.
Unlike, by the way,
British land.
No one talks about that.
You won't report that.
Well, no, look, look at these --
look at these --
look at these charts here.
Very impressive.
Four colors.
I walked right into Kinko's,
I saw this chart on the wall,
I said, boom, that's the chart,
then the Kinko's guy
started with all this,
"Sir, that's just a sample chart
to demonstrate our printing,"
so there may be
some problems with Kinko's,
but we're looking into Staples.
We're looking into Office Max.
A lot of people are calling them
Stinko's, by the way.
People are dying.
That's right.
It is, as they say, what it is.
I love that saying.
It is what it is.
Or as they say in French --
people say, hakuna matata.
America, excuse me --
America is far lower
than the world.
-Lower than the world?
-That's right.
When other countries look at us,
they think, America,
lower than the world.
You know, we have some of
the best doctors around.
Great doctors.
Some even women doctors.
I call them nurses.
-The other day a reporter asked
you about Ghislaine Maxwell.
You said, "I just wish
her well, frankly."
-I do. I do wish her well.
I wish a lot of people well.
I actually sent her something
at, you know, the jail.
It was a bear, or as we call it,
a Build-A-Bear,
and when you squeeze
its hand, it says,
"Shh, snitches get stitches."
Excuse me.
What even is Axios?
When I said I'd do this,
I thought I was going
to be interviewed by a cologne
bottle I saw at Neiman Marcus.
Axios by Jimmy Choo.
Sometimes I could put my --
I'll put my hands out like this.
Sometimes I give you two palms.
Sometimes I go in, out,
in, out, in, out.
-Sir, the the question was
how will you ensure hospitals
don't reach capacity?
-Well, no, look at these.
These are the latest numbers,
Jonathan.
Maybe you have more
up-to-date numbers.
You're Australian.
I know Australia is, what,
one day ahead
or is it two days ahead?
I haven't been to Europe
in a long time.
Who are you with again?
Axios Hollywood?
Why didn't they
send Mario Lopez?
I love Mario Lopez.
Everyone loves Mario Lopez.
-Interesting interview.
Yeah, it was a rough night
for Trump.
Unfortunately, things didn't get
much better for him today.
During a bill signing, he was
talking about national parks,
and he had a little trouble
reading the word Yosemite.
Watch this.
-We want every American child
to have access to pristine
outdoor spaces.
When they gaze upon Yo-semite's
towering sequoias.
[ Laughter ]
-"America's full of beauty,
from Yo-semite's..."
[ Laughter ]
"...National Park
to the mighty Miss-peepee River.
[ Laughter ]
"To the Appalachian Mountains
to New York's Viagra Falls."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Let's get to some other news.
Listen to this. I saw that Kraft
is replacing the word dinner
with breakfast on its iconic
blue macaroni and cheese box.
Look at this.
Yeah. For breakfast. Yeah.
I'm excited about it because now
I can finally stop
melting Kraft
singles on my Cheerios.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Velveeta is like,
"Who knew we'd be
the classy brand?"
Mac and cheese for breakfast.
In a related story,
the C.E.O. of Kraft
must be going
through a divorce.
And finally, this isn't good.
At a museum in Italy,
a tourist snapped three toes off
a 19th century statue
while posing for a photo.
Here's the moment
where it happened.
Check it out.
Oh, yeah.
When the security guard
saw three toes on the floor,
he was like,
"Okay, which three statues
are missing their penises?"
[ Laughter ]
Afterwards the tourist was like,
"It is what it is."